- [Narrator] He's Donald
Pup, the Trump pup!
- [Donald Trump] You know
Donald Pup, this season
isn't just about
presents, it's about
the celebration of
one special man: me.
I personally won the
war on Christmas,
the one war bone spurs
couldn't keep me out of.
So what do you want for
Christmas, Donald Pup?
♪ Trump Pup, filling
up stockings ♪
♪ Trump Pup,
redistributing presents ♪
♪ Trump Pup, shopping
spree at the mall ♪
♪ Trump Pup, lost
in this hallway ♪
♪ Trump Pup, opening packages ♪
- [Trump Pup] Aroo?
- [Mr. Meuller] Come
with me, Trump Pup,
you've been indicted.
- [Donald Trump] Wait,
please, Mr. Meuller,
think of the family, me, Don
Jr., Eric, Jared and Ivanka.
Ah, forget it - you're fired.
♪ Lu, lu, lu, lu,
lu, lu, lu, lu, lu ♪
- [Narrator] It's a
Christmas miracle!
♪ lu, lu, lu, lu, lu, lu ♪